E aí
[Música]
e no final de 290 não tinha 18 anos e
morava em uma pequena cidade de Minas e
peguei um ônibus sentido a capital Belo
Horizonte o objetivo era fazer um curso
de multimídia naquela época eu era
fascinado com aquelas revistas que eu
comprava na banca que vinha o CD e lá
vinha jogos aplicativos eu queria fazer
aquilo na semana que eu fiquei em Belo
Horizonte Aproveitei uma oportunidade e
vir uma entrevista de emprego era uma
empresa de informática Não sei precisar
o nome e entrei no processo seletivo
várias perguntas técnicas mais duas me
chamaram atenção a primeira O que você
acha que vai vender pela internet aliás
naquele período muito se falava de venda
na internet já vi um burburinho e um
pouco de atividade
e eu respondi produtos de supermercado
aliás produtos Supermercados são iguais
muitas vezes reposição e nunca vi
sentido pegar a longas filas para pagar
no caixa a segunda pergunta era o que
você acha que não irá vender pela
internet eu pensei pensei e logo
responde vestuário calçado Aliás não faz
sentido algum eu comprar na internet
você não vou poder experimentar eu
preciso dinheiro até uma loja física
enfim
e os homens 2000 chegavam e com ele o
tal do bug do milênio não aconteceu mas
outro fenômeno muito interessante
aconteceu as chamadas empresas pontocom
naquela época super valorizadas não é
apresentar os resultados e suas ações
despencaram foi a primeira queda no
mercado de e-commerce porém nesse mesmo
período algumas empresas começaram
destacar os sites de compra coletiva
alguns sites que vendiam eletrônicos
livros CDs ficava por aí mas no meio de
tudo isso alguns players começaram
destacar entre eles um grande site que
evoluiu ao longo dos anos de venda de
calçados
e é eu vivi para mim desmentir e talvez
talvez seja por isso que eu não passei
naquela prova mas enfim isso não importa
o que importa é que o e como esse
continua caminhando caminhando me dado
momento algo muito importante aconteceu
o momento onde as operadoras de telefone
anunciaram que nós poderíamos ter
internet na Palma das nossas mãos nos
nossos celulares por alguns centavos por
dia nesse período ocorreu a
democratização na internet e muitos
usuários passaram a pesquisar estudar
buscar produtos buscar serviços e enfim
a internet deslanchou a gente podia tela
do nosso lado a todo momento
e os números foram crescendo ano após
ano um crescimento de dois dígitos até
então muito bom os novos modelos de
negócio foram surgindo além do
tradicional varejo bicho se onde
empresas vendem para consumidores finais
outros modelos interessantes como
atacado onde distribuidores e
fabricantes possam seus catálogos
Lojistas com 100 específica consegue ver
produtos preços e adquirir seus produtos
os modelos muito interessantes como
assinatura e recorrência pela internet é
preciso de produtos naturais fazendo
combos de recorrência de assinatura um
outro modelo interessante aluguel
aluguel de vestidos de festa aluguel de
bolsas apoiando a economia sustentável
economia circular EA inclusive muito
também vem avançando a questão das
Embalagens embalagens recicláveis no
pensamento de sustentabilidade modelos
de sítio se onde pessoas vendem para
pessoas também apoiando a circularidade
dos objetos e por fim os marketplaces os
marketplaces são shoppings aonde
Lojistas colocam seus produtos e quando
ocorre vendas cada um distribui na
cadeia logística a sem falar dos
infoprodutos
os produtores pessoas físicas
profissionais criam seus cursos suas
receitas Suas dicas de viagem e
monetizam através de plataformas pois
bem o mercado e é como esse continua
evoluindo até que Então chegou a
pandemia
o lock Down fomos todos para casa e
enfim o Home Office virou verdade nesse
momento as pessoas precisavam adquirir
bens e serviços e a internet foi enfim
novamente a grande estrela nesse momento
muitas empresas fizeram bons
faturamentos mas o grande. Dessa
história foi o número de novos usuários
que nunca tinham comprado pela internet
e a partir desse momento passaram a
estar habilitadas para compra online e
veja só existe aquela pessoa Talvez não
dessa geração mas que tem o poder de
compra e nunca teve um cartão de crédito
e nunca fez uma compra online durante a
pandemia a sua filha que antes geravam
boleto entregava para ela para pagar
agora ela recebeu um cartão de
e começou a vender online a comprar
online
e esse número de clientes entrantes para
o ecommerce aconteceu Aconteceu algo
muito interessante os Lojistas viram que
precisavam estar no canal online e a
porta de entrada para todas as empresas
geralmente são as redes sociais muito
acessíveis postar no Instagram Facebook
vender pelo WhatsApp sim isso é possível
aliás Tem um ditado que diz o artista
vai aonde o povo está isso é a empresa
que encontrar seu público ela logo vai
para as redes sociais um local onde tem
conteúdo onde tem produtos e até
servente porém é uma venda 1 a 1 o
atendimento é um a um quando alguém quer
saber o preço de um produto ele precisa
escrever esperar uma resposta se pode
parcelar se pode entregar no meu bairro
você tem garantia
e tem aquele descontinho todo esse
diálogo pode durar dias pode durar
muitos dias enfim se uma empresa de fato
precisa vender online ela tem que
enxergar em qual degrau da escala
digital ela está o primeiro degrau é
quando ela não utiliza canais digitais
para venda aí ela começa a vender nas
redes sociais nos aplicativos de
mensagem ou até mesmo em alguns
Marketplace pois bem nesse momento o
próprio gestor o dono ou algum
funcionário consegue fazer essa Essa
gestão de vendas mas existe o terceiro
degrau ele constrói a sua loja própria o
seu é como se somente nesse ambiente ele
consegue controlar tudo porque enquanto
nas redes sociais ou em outras marcas
Places a empresa joga o jogo de quem é o
dono dessa rede nada mal está lá mas o
jogo
E conforme as regras que são colocadas
ao ter uma loja virtual você escolhe
qual o produto vai para vitrine Qual é a
promoção Qual o tempo de entrega e aí A
gestão é sua para fazer a venda online
aliás muitas pessoas usam os buscadores
quando quer comprar um produto e o
resultado de busca orgânica privilegia
os sites e as lojas virtuais
e enfim isso é muito interessante para
todo mundo que ainda não deu esse passo
e eu consigo dizer para vocês que
existem dois grupos de pessoas que ainda
não vendem pela internet o primeiro
grupo são aquelas pessoas que não
acreditam haver online Isso mesmo talvez
porque ela não compra online ou ela tem
medo de trazer essa cultura de venda
para dentro da sua empresa para essas
pessoas eu posso dizer Nos vemos no
futuro o segundo grupo de pessoas que
não vende pela internet são aquelas
pessoas que não entendem desses paranauê
e o que é plataforma O que é marketing
digital também não sei quanto eu invisto
na minha campanha de marketing o qual
empresa eu vou contratar para essas
pessoas existe uma solução à busca por
conhecimento e a busca por profissionais
e empresas que podem apoiar ali a se
contar uma coisa para vocês o homem mais
rico do mundo e a mulher brasileira mais
rica tem algo em comum Ambos são
varejistas online Ambos não tiveram que
digitar linhas de código para construir
suas páginas essas pessoas simplesmente
acreditaram na tecnologia como mola
propulsora dos seus negócios buscaram
equipes treinaram e acreditaram
E aí eles estão na competição Global
pelo mercado de Accorsi
eu queria dizer mais uma coisa para
vocês a transformação digital Quer algo
necessário em todas as empresas para mim
não tem muito a ver com um monte de
palavras estrangeiras ou também não tem
a ver com uma grande tecnologia
disruptiva A transformação digital tem a
ver com velocidade velocidade de
transformação e como no mundo real em
cada cada empresa disputa o mercado e
que numa disputa velocidade é essencial
e com a tecnologia que a empresa
consegue adquirir velocidade
e eu fico pensando que se eu pudesse
voltar lá nos anos 90 e encontrar aquele
menino de 18 anos que pensava em criar
multimídia e fazer CD E se ele me
perguntar se o que é possível vender
pela internet eu diria para ele tudo
absolutamente tudo e por que isso porque
a tecnologia transformou o módulo de
vender no mundo Muito obrigado